because my brother went on to be like
third in the nation in his age group for
running and I was just like I just want
to running so then I quit running and I
did volleyball and then all my mom
my mom I did basketball my mom puts all
I was just like so mad like I used to
get so mad about this but it's funny I
don't know when the dynamic changed with
my brother because I used to be
competitive with him I mean I had to
have been if you know he I was mad he
joined the running team but some Dynamic
changed where I was just like you know
I'm just unbelievably proud of him he's
gonna be richer than I ever will he's
gonna do more and like impact the world
in ways that like I mean who knows I
mean you know YouTube is like
a different animal but
it's not like I hope he does I hope he
like I hope he runs for president I hope
he like
builds what
I don't know because
I I'm just really proud of him